[Music]
you spend week studying for an important
test on the big day you wait nervously
as your teacher hands it out you're
working your way through when you're
asked to define ataraxia you know you've
seen it before but your mind goes blank
what just happened the answer lies in
the complex relationship between stress
and memory there are many types and
degrees of stress in different kinds of
memory but we're going to focus on how
short-term stress impacts your memory
for facts to start it helps to
understand how this kind of memory works
facts you read here or study become
memories through a process with three
main steps first comes acquisition the
moment you encounter a new piece of
information each sensory experience
activates a unique set of brain areas in
order to become lasting memories these
sensory experiences have to be
consolidated by the hippocampus
influenced by the amygdala which
emphasizes experiences associated with
strong emotions the hippocampus then
encodes memories probably by
strengthening the synaptic connections
stimulated during the original sensory
experience once a memory has been
encoded it can be remembered or
retrieved later memories are stored all
over the brain and it's likely the
prefrontal cortex that signals for their
retrieval so how to stress affect each
of these stages in the first two stages
moderate stress can actually help
experiences enter your memory your brain
responds to stressful stimuli by
releasing hormones known as
corticosteroids which activate a process
of threat detection and threat response
in the amygdala the amygdala prompts
your hippocampus to consolidate the
stress inducing experience into a memory
meanwhile the flood of corticosteroids
from stress stimulates your hippocampus
also prompting memory consolidation but
even though some stress can be helpful
extreme and chronic stress can have the
opposite effect
researchers have tested this by
injecting rats directly with stress
hormones as they gradually increased the
dose of corticosteroids the rats
performance when memory tests increased
at first but dropped off at higher doses
in humans we see a similar positive
effect
with moderate stress but that only
appears when the stress is related to
the memory task
so while time pressure might help you
memorize a list having a friend scare
you will not and the weeks months or
even years of sustained corticosteroids
that result from chronic stress can
damage the hippocampus and decrease your
ability to form new memories it would be
nice if some stress also helped us
remember facts but unfortunately the
opposite is true the act of remembering
relies on the prefrontal cortex which
governs thought attention and reasoning
when corticosteroids stimulate the
amygdala the amygdala inhibits or
lessens the activity of the prefrontal
cortex the reason for this inhibition is
so the fight flight freeze response can
overrule slower more recent thought in a
dangerous situation but that can also
have the unfortunate effect of making
your mind go blank during a test and
then the act of trying to remember can
itself be a stressor leading to a
vicious cycle of more corticosteroid
release and an even smaller chance of
remembering so what can you do to turn
stress to your advantage and stay calm
and collected when it matters the most
first if you know a stressful situation
like a test is coming try preparing and
conditions similar to the stressful
environment novelty can be a stressor
completing practice questions under time
pressure or seated at a desk rather than
on a couch can make your stress response
to these circumstances less sensitive
during the test itself exercise is
another useful tool increasing your
heart and breathing rate is linked to
chemical changes in your brain that help
reduce anxiety and increase your sense
of well-being regular exercise is also
widely thought to improve sleeping
patterns which comes in handy the night
before a test and on the actual test day
try taking deep breaths to counteract
your body's fight flight freeze response
deep breathing exercises have shown
measurable reduction in test anxiety in
groups ranging from third graders to
nursing students so the next time you
find your mind going blank at a critical
moment take a few deep breaths until you
remember ataraxia
a state of calmness free from anxiety
check out these videos to learn how
stress affects your brain and your body
[Music]